hey youtubers is Charlie so the Game of
Thrones Season 5 trailer dropped way
earlier than I expected so this is going
to be a breakdown of all that footage
I'm also starting a new round of the
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video it's just going to be a $20
Amazon gift card so here we go down to
business so I'm going to try and avoid
liberal spoilers but just general
spoiler warning for everything through
season 4 on the show so here we go first
thing did not like the David Bowie
heroes cover I could have done without
that it spliced with footage of Jamie
and Cersei standing over Tywin's body
and Baylor cept I know we all knew Tywin
was going to be in season 5 it probably
is a corpse and this just confirms that
this is also something of foreshadowing
to people in the future that they'll
fail to protect if you have read the
books and you do want to comment on who
those people are that they fail to
protect in the future please just use
spoiler tags in the comments this Bay up
here in the north this is
eastwatch-by-the-sea it's the port that
ships go to whenever they're traveling
to the wall I can't make out who all
these people on the boats are but
Stannis would have brought his men here
last season whatever they landed
remember they have a bunch of wildlings
there now the battle is over they won
the battle so they got to decide what to
do with the wildlings that are still
alive then we get the Littlefinger
voiceover he's talking to Sansa saying
there's no justice in this world
not unless we make it it looks like
they've left the Eyrie now they're
traveling around the Vale it's cut
against footage of bran and Jaime
drawing swords there have been liberal
spoilers about where they're going how
their storyline has changed there are
some shots of them in the trailer that
I'll talk about but try to avoid super
spoilers when you're talking about them
here we see our first shots of the sons
of the harpy wearing masks that's in
Mereen then we jump all the way to Dorne
brand new place we see Obara using her
whip which is funny because it's looks
like she's torturing someone here in the
ground
she's Oberyn Martell his oldest daughter
the oldest of the sand snakes and the
best warrior of all of them they're all
good warriors but she's just the best
but it all looks like they're standing
here in the background next to ilaria
sand so they might be trying to get
information from someone vengeance is a
big theme for the Martel's in the wake
of over and steth so they might just be
torturing someone from King's Landing
this here is Sun spear with the water
gardens it's the palace that Prince
Doran spends his time hiding out at he's
really weak so he stays out of public
sight just so the illusion of his health
isn't shattered like all of his people
just
he's totally normal so here this Sansa
scene this is actually really big
Littlefinger says avenge them sophie
Turner said Sansa was going to have some
traumatic experiences in season five
it's possible that the producers gave
some aspects of Lady Stoneheart story to
Sansa maybe not in a literal way but
Sansa might take on a spirit of
vengeance
it would just be awesome to see her kill
someone our little Sansa grown up
stabbing people in the face so this
looks like more eastwatch-by-the-sea
Faris says I believe men of talent have
a part to play in the war to come this
balcony he's standing out it looks like
he and Tyrion are in Pentos at Illyrio's
home he's talking about Tyrion he's
trying to get Tyrion to help him in his
cause to put someone worthy on the Iron
Throne
this footage is actually it's cut with
Jon Snow and the Nights Watch
Brotherhood rallying Cersei in King's
Landing
van Sansa then Margaery all these people
here this is basically contenders for
the Iron Throne just cut in with Faris's
speech Daenerys says I'm not going to
stop the wheel I'm going to break it and
we get a shot of Sir Jorah and the
marine fighting pits sucks to be him
she's trying to abolish slavery in
slavers Bay like that it's been her
mission since season four as we saw any
time she leaves a place like a city of
bid city like young Kai all the rats
flood back in and starts slaving again
so these people that are fighting her
those are the wise masters they
represent the old guard the people that
still want to slave this looks like it
might be a gift from house Martell or
Varys I thought it might be Tywin's
chain of office but I thought that that
was left on his body and a lot of people
are pissed that we're not going to seek
even lannister it does really look like
tywin's chain of office though it is
just hard to zoom the footage in just
because it's a little fuzzy this bonfire
here looks like mellow Sandra's latest
attempt at working some big-time magic
bearded Tyrion here reaffirms his desire
to continue living
so here's Jon Snow entering what looks
like some sort of conflict it looks like
he's wearing a wildling outfit so
Stannis and the Nights Watch could have
already integrated the wildlings into
their forces here's a full shot of Jamie
and Dorne
I guess we don't need to worry about
spoiling that anymore they stuck in the
trailer that was actually one of the
biggest surprises of the trailer was
seeing like full-on Jamie in Dorne I
didn't think they were going to include
that this actually looks like it might
be tying sand trying to seduce him so
it's
possible that if you've read the books
they're combining eros oak arts part and
giving it to Jamie and give me the
Ariane Martel part to tyene sand it just
it makes sense because that's a really
important storyline but they cut out
some of the important characters so they
have to give that story to someone else
so here I'm actually happy to see that
the Queen of thorns made it in Diana
Rigg was awesome last year so it's great
to see that she's back in season five
her line they'll never find what's left
of you is just is cuts with battle
scenes from all over the place up at the
Nights Watch down here and Dorne here
actually this will make people really
happy this is a shot of Quaithe the
graffiti in the background just just
says wise masters they're the opposing
force they're like the antagonists and
marine technically the wise masters are
from young Kai but I don't think they're
leaving marine in terms of location so
it looks like they've come to marine
here's a quick shot of Ramsey and reek
cut with Jaime and Bronn fighting
Dornish soldiers the voiceover this is
the high Sparrow that we hear in the
background he's saying strip away the
gold knock down the statues he just an
advocate of the people so he hates what
he considers to be vulgar displays of
wealth so he's not a huge fan of the
crown these people running through the
streets smashing things it looks like
they might be faith militant this person
could either be the new Marcela it could
be Maggy the Frog it's kind of hard to
tell there aren't that many big
characters that have that color of hair
they just they aged merciless character
up so she's not a little girl anymore
then this is actually really cool we see
Arya getting ready to enter the house of
black and white and Braavos I know
everyone was really pumped about that
the voiceover ends with this is what
remains is Arya looks at Needle it just
meant to show that needle is all that's
left of Arya's former life as Arya Stark
so she's trying to transition to a new
life and needle is just like the last
thing she has left that reminds her of
her old life these soldiers bear the
symbol of house Aeryn so they're
probably writing with Sansa and
Littlefinger around the Vale this bat
board actually it's hard to tell who's
standing at it but these symbols on it
look like flayed men so this could be
Stannis's map board that'd be awesome if
he brought that giant table map from
Dragonstone
think about what that implies Stannis
mapping out troop locations for the
Bolton's remember they were headed for
Winterfell at the end of season 4 here
Tyrion and Varys just cap off their
speech saying Daenerys is the right girl
for the job
Faris is just trying to get Tyrion to
back Daenerys
a lot of people are upset that young
Griff isn't going to be in the show it
sounds like they're just cutting
straight to Daenerys and here we finally
get a beautiful shot of a huge drogue on
getting ready to melt a bunch of
people's faces off
if you thought drogon was cool in season
four you had you have no idea he's going
to be enormous think about how fast he
grew between seasons two and three and
then three and four yeah he's going to
be like that much bigger in season five
the really cool thing about dragons is
is there's really no limit to the amount
they can grow it's just dependent upon
their ability to find food although when
you do chain them up it does stunt their
growth so that's why dinner says other
two dragons aren't as big
here's more eastwatch-by-the-sea then
then it looks like the sandai is totally
going to go for it with gray worm
Daenerys presiding over some slave
fights and the fighting pits
Melisandre here getting ready to have
sex ruin someone else's life up at the
wall seems like any time she has sex
with someone she's ruining their life so
don't have sex with Melisandre here's
the nearest with her unsullied marching
around hilarious and back Endor into the
water gardens they're holding Spears at
her so she might be in the presence of
Prince Doran this here looks like it
might be Bowen Marsh he's one of the new
characters in season five he's a Nights
Watch character Brienne and Podrick on
the run then we have open revolt in
marine it just it looks like the sons of
the harpy are fighting Daenerys is
unsullied in the streets she goes down
here we have Margaery and Tommen it
looks like she's getting ready to do
something really naughty then all-out
craziness in the fighting pits and a
shot of the statue being torn off the
top of the pyramid that's just meant to
imply that rulers will face a lot of
opposition from their people it all
parts of the world I guess you could
subtitle season 5 vengeance or uprising
or maybe revolt just depending on whose
POV you're taking so here's my big
question for you guys you know of all
the crazy new things are going to be
doing in the new places we're going to
visit what are you most looking forward
to like re and Braavos at the house of
black and white or say like house
Martell in Dorne I'm personally I would
say you know both of the things are
probably pretty equal but I think house
Martell is going to be pretty awesome so
like I said a new round of the giveaway
starts now all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on this video so I'm going to do a Q&A
tomorrow we'll announce the winners and
actually instead of gift certificates
I'm giving away two pre-orders for
episode two of the telltale Game sorry I
forgot about that the beginning of the
video it's going to be a great sea
I'll be doing all the same types of
bonus videos that I did last year so
I'll be doing bonus videos episode
reviews and then Q&A so I'll be like
three Game of Thrones videos a week
it'll be a lot of fun I'm really excited
if HBO posts a higher quality version of
the trailer tomorrow I'll just I'll post
that I'll attach it to my QA while you
guys wait for that you can click here to
learn all about the Citadel masters and
you can click here for my mance rayder
video thank you so much for watching so
let's all high-five Game of Thrones is
almost here it's almost here
you